There are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time, so we gathered
some of the most-hyped products from April
to test for ourselves.
We have two new face products
from One/Size Beauty,
the Cheek Clapper 3D blush trio palette
and the Made for Shade
bronze and sculpt trio.
Let's get into the sculpt palette first.
I used a mix of the bottom two shades,
and they brought some
much-needed warmth for my face.
They blend really nicely and smoothly.
These are nice bronzers,
but I think the real star of the show here
is the blush palette.
If I had to pick one of these two palettes
to splurge on, it would
definitely be this one.
These are three different formulas,
a flex cream, a full-impact
matte,
and a hyper sheen.
I went in with a very light hand
because these are really pigmented,
and they just look really beautiful
and smooth on the skin.
The color can be built up or toned down
as much as you want,
which I think is my favorite
thing about this palette.
There are just so many
different ways you can use it,
and all the formulas
work so nicely together.
Rare Beauty just released the
Positive Light tinted
moisturizer with SPF 20.
I was so happy that this had SPF in it.
The formula felt thicker
and looked more full-coverage
than I expected.
Also, this was a shade
or two too light for me,
so ignore that.
It does sheer out as you apply it,
so it looks less like a foundation
and more like a tinted moisturizer.
I applied the rest of
my powder makeup on top
and honestly wasn't loving how it looked.
I felt like it kept building up
in the dry patches around my nose
and just looked a little too textured.
But then I redid my makeup
with all cream products
on top of this tinted moisturizer,
and it looked so much better,
just super dewy and fresh.
So I much preferred using
it with cream products.
This is the NYX Wonder
Stick cream blush contour,
and it's literally a blush stick
that you use to contour your face.
There's a lighter shade
that's meant to be used as a blush
and a deeper shade that you contour with.
I have never contoured with blush,
so I was really intrigued by this.
I applied the darker shade
wherever I would normally contour
and the lighter shade above it
and then blended it out.
This isn't the easiest formula to blend,
but I eventually got
it looking pretty good.
I didn't hate the blush-contour look.
I just think this blush
formula isn't great,
and I've definitely tried
better at the drugstore.
I haven't experimented
much with correctors,
but I saw a TikTok recommending this one,
the Benefit Boi-ing Bright On
brightening undereye concealer.
It has this peachy color
to counteract the darkness
underneath the eyes.
I tested it out before applying makeup,
and I could see a difference already.
So then I applied a small
amount, blended that,
then applied concealer on top,
and I think it did make a difference.
My under-eyes looked brighter than usual.
I definitely noticed less darkness
than when I just use concealer,
and the product didn't do anything weird
to the concealer I applied on top.
It didn't make it patchy or bunch up,
so I'm actually really into this.
I realized later you're just supposed
to wear this on its own,
which I clearly did not do.
But I was still happy with the results.
Charlotte Tilbury came out
with a new Pillow Talk collection
inspired by its popular
lipstick in Pillow Talk,
so I picked up a few of the products.
I already love the Beauty Light Wands,
so I knew that I would love
this Pillow Talk shade.
It's super glowy and makes
the skin look so beautiful.
The Multi-Glow highlighter
was a new product for me.
The packaging is so pretty.
I didn't even want to touch it, but I did.
It has this almost soft blurring effect
that looks really nice.
And it's not glittery at all,
just like a soft glow.
The product I was most excited to try
was actually the mascara
in the shade Dream Pop.
It's described as a berry-brown shade.
I don't think I have ever tried
a colored mascara before,
but I applied it like I normally would,
and I actually love the color.
The formula isn't my favorite,
and neither is the brush,
but I think the color
was actually flattering on my eyes.
It's supposed to bring out
the amber in brown eyes.
I don't know if that's what's happening,
but it did make my eyes look
really sparkly, which I love.
I saw that Flower Beauty had this
Spotlight liquid highlighter
that looked a lot like
the Charlotte Tilbury
Light Wand in the Pillow Talk shade,
so I really wanted to compare the two
to see if it was a dupe.
The shades aren't exactly the same,
but they're super close.
Both are so easy to blend out
and look more natural and dewy on the skin
than a powder highlight does.
I think the Charlotte Tilbury one
is a bit more reflective
than the Flower Beauty one,
but the effect is definitely similar.
The Flower Beauty one looks
just as beautiful on the skin,
and it's almost $30 cheaper.
So I highly recommend this if you haven't
gotten the chance to try the Light Wands.
I'm an East Coast girl,
so I was so excited when I saw
that ELF collabed with Dunkin'.
This was such a fun, cute idea.
This huge doughnut
sponge was so ridiculous,
I had to try it out.
It's big even before wetting,
and it was pretty hard at first.
But it doubled in size once I wet it,
and it became a lot softer and squishier.
I'm not gonna lie,
applying foundation with
this is kind of great
because it's so big.
It literally applies
foundation in five seconds.
I decided to use it to
apply all my other makeup,
and the size does get more
difficult to work with
the more precise you're trying to be.
You can see that I was accidentally
spreading my blush up way too high.
But I think overall, the
makeup came out looking good.
Obviously, this is more like a novelty
than a super-useful makeup tool,
but it comes in handy if you
want to apply makeup quickly.
I also ordered the Glazed
for Days lip gloss set
because I cannot resist an orange gloss,
let alone an orange gloss
that smells like glazed doughnuts.
This is a really nice gloss.
The color is pretty sheer,
but for the price point,
I think this formula is super glossy
and comfortable on the lips.